you think you're going to get the  vaccine soon yeah well i'm 91  i figured we're supposed to be right  after the uh the  nursing homes and right after the uh the  healthcare people but i haven't  i called up my doctor the other day and  i said  because i wanted to find out what the  procedure is you know the protocol and  all that  and he said we don't know we haven't  gotten any word  from from the county he said you might  uh  you might try ralph's ralph's  wait dude it's a grocery store yeah  what do you think about i don't trust  ghost you know  i don't want the guy saying you know yes  phil yeah when you get finished putting  the lettuce away  give this guy a shot okay  no no it's that long thin needle the lip  that's it  don't please don't go to ralph i know  they have a pharmacy section but don't  go to ralph's  okay i may try ace hardware i don't know